dr. mark Feuerstein played cliff Calley
back in the day in the popular series of
West Wing remember that yes that was
going back I don't know walk down memory
lane how is that you're welcome now he's
throwing in a new comedy inspired by his
own life it's called nain JKL this
timing plays Josh Roberts a newly
divorced actor who moves home to his New
York City apartment and right next door
are his medals and parents his brother
and sister-in-law and their newborn baby
in this preview josh has a hard time
dating because mom right next door
maybe she'll go away understand your
relationship with your neighbor
beautiful especially at night we had our
moment of course I'm okay I was in your
apartment ten seconds ago first I don't
like your tone that actor you always go
up against got a terrible did you in his
new play mark Feuerstein is also
co-creator and executive producer of the
series welcome to the table and the CBS
family thank you that's a real you like
looking I look up to you people anyway
March off but I love the dialogue where
she goes wait I don't like your tone
yeah that's that's such a mom line I
don't like your tone and linda lavin is
so fun thanks your mom your own family
mark what do you mean it is it is
loosely based on my own family there was
a period of time when I was shooting the
show Royal Pains here in New York and I
have a wife and three kids in LA so to
save money I lived in the apartment that
my parents owned next door to the one
that I grew up in so every morning my
father would come in and his
tighty-whiteys mark what do you want for
breakfast Iran eggs you want french
toast and at night after a 15-hour day
of shooting my mother would be waiting
by the door like a gunslinger in the
night
we'd like to come in for a salad maybe a
black and white cookie pick a bagel
anyway that was my day and then for a
period of two years my brother his wife
and their baby we're living in the
apartment on the other side so it was
like Feuerstein sandwich it is a show
and I talked to a producer we're like
this is a show a show this falls into
the category of right what you know
that's right that's exactly what were
like kind of the advice that I followed
that led me to create the show with my
wife Dana Kline who is a brilliant
writer and we were lucky enough to get
to help create the show brilliant writer
and great taste in men we should say
thank you yeah but let me think about
this Marc for just a second is it hard
writing and working with your wife
listen she's an accomplished writer
because she works she wrote with friends
to for a while so she's not new to this
profession what's it like with the two
of you working together it was a natural
progression because I've worked for her
in my household for the last 15 years we
just brought it to the workplace she's
fantastic I mean she wrote for friends
for fresh-off-the-boat she had a show on
CBS called friends with better lives and
she knows my family I mean who knows
this material better than my wife and so
I'm so lucky to get to work with her
every day and we spend so much time
together and we've only had a few
moments of tension we haven't killed
each other yet and our kids come to the
tapings and it's now a family affair
both in the source material and in the
creation of the show but thought that
how'd you get turned into acting because
there I think I read somewhere you would
Princeton and thought about either
international relations yes Wow yes I
would have been talking to you on a very
different front for many years I hope
but I I had been following you know the
track to get into a good college and
then the track as a New York private
school kid to get into a good law school
and I was trying to build a resume at
all times and then one day fate just
took me to an audition for a play and it
changed my life I was just so inspired I
felt like that was home it just felt
right yeah that whether it was the rush
of making people laugh or cry or just
telling stories I fell in love with it
and I did 15 plays at college and went
to London to study acting and Here I am
I'd say yeah they were not thrilled at
first but they were incredibly
supportive that I didn't know that only
behind my back would they share that
they were you know like we sent you to a
great college and now but they've been
so great and then we've got Linda Lavin
and Elliott Gould playing your parents
what does what is that like for your
parents to see how those two playing
them you know they're so thrilled
because I love Elliott Gould and they
love Linda Lavin and the two of them
have such amazing chemistry together we
had obnoxious into play yeah so there
was there was an awkward moment during
the taping of the pilot when my mother
the character of my mother yells at the
character of my brother she goes you
don't like to visit with me and then I
turned to my mother and yell neither do
i and then they'd yell cut and I run to
my real mother who's in the audience at
the taping Goma of course I love to be
this is just a TV show we just wrote a
comedy based on my life and we have to
be funny but of course my favorite thing
is to sit with you and talk about the
day's events so yes there are awkward
moments guitars are created press with
me all day yesterday my father and I
cooked his mother's spaghetti on the
Rachael Ray Show yesterday we just I
mean they're very supportive well let's
just say this we are all pulling for you
as a member of the CBS family thank you
very excited I'm so thrilled to be here
and we're so excited to radio and say
yes thank you thank much mark Feuerstein
and Dana Klein pullin for you guys you
can watch the series premiere of nine
JKL on monday night at 8:30 7:30 central
right here on you better get used to it
on CBS
yeah